When she was a kid LaDonna Powell would go to Easter parties at her mom's work. It was great, because her mom worked at JFK airport in New York City. LaDonna and her brothers and sisters and cousins would gather Easter eggs out on a parking lot by the tarmac in what's now the American Airlines terminal. Planes were taking off and landing right overhead. They liked that.
LaDonna Powell小时候常去她妈妈工作的单位参加复活节聚会。那感觉很棒，因为她妈妈在纽约肯尼迪机场工作。LaDonna和她的兄弟姐妹及堂表亲们会在停机坪旁的一个停车场捡复活节彩蛋，那里现在是美国航空公司的航站楼。飞机就在头顶起降。他们喜欢那样。
A bunch of her family works at JFK. Her mom makes airplane meals, but there's also her uncle, two aunts, three cousins, and her sister. Everybody has a role. They feed the passengers, they deliver their bags, they clean up the planes after them. And when she was 20, LaDonna found her role-- she'd keep the airport safe. She got a job with TSA. She scanned bags and laptops. She took it seriously. Like, she would picture the pipeline that runs below the airport, carrying millions of gallons of jet fuel, blowing up if there were any kind of bomb.
她家有好几个人都在肯尼迪机场工作。她妈妈负责做飞机餐，此外还有她叔叔、两个阿姨、三个堂表亲和她妹妹。每个人都有自己的职责。他们为乘客供餐、运送行李、在乘客下机后清理机舱。20岁时，LaDonna找到了自己的角色——保障机场安全。她进入美国运输安全管理局（TSA）工作。她负责扫描行李和笔记本电脑。她非常认真。比如，她会想象机场下方那条输送数百万加仑航空煤油的管道，如果发生任何爆炸，后果不堪设想。
Like, if the bomb goes off in this airport, what happens to everyone here, everyone that I care about if we don't commit and do our job properly here? It was like, I used to have this terrible dream of a woman walking up to me and pressing, igniting a bomb. Every time-- I would go to sleep and have this dream all the time. So when I came to work, I was always very adamant on staring at the X-ray machine.
比如，如果这个机场发生爆炸，如果不尽职尽责，这里的所有人，我所关心的人会怎样？我以前常做噩梦，梦见一个女人走近我，然后按下引爆器。每次睡着都会做这个梦。所以上班时，我总是非常执着地盯着X光机。
After a few years at TSA, she moved to a different job, this one out on the tarmac with a private security firm that works at the airport, a firm that eventually became part of Allied Universal, which is a huge company-- the largest security firm in North America, with 150,000 employees all across the country. At JFK, Allied guards screen the vehicles and the airplane catering trucks and all the other stuff that's down there on the runway. LaDonna was excited to work with them. She went through training and then was assigned to shadow a more senior guard.
在TSA工作几年后，她换了一份工作，是在停机坪上一家为机场服务的私营安保公司。该公司后来成了Allied Universal的一部分，这是一家庞大的公司——北美最大的安保公司，在全国拥有15万名员工。在肯尼迪机场，Allied的保安负责检查车辆、飞机配餐车以及跑道上的所有其他物资。LaDonna很兴奋能加入他们。她通过了培训，然后被指派跟随一名资深保安实习。
My first day in the field was not great. I was put with this guy. He was an older white guy. And he was very nice to me but very mean to the people we were screening going onto the runway, because a lot of the duty-free trucks come through that load the planes with food for first class, and he was saying the nastiest things to them.
我在现场的第一天表现并不好。我被分配给那个家伙。他是一个上了年纪的白人。他对我很客气，但对我们要检查进入跑道的人却非常刻薄，因为很多免税品卡车都要经过那里，为头等舱装载食物，他对这些人说的话非常难听。
Quick warning that we've un-beeped the curse words here on the podcast. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, maybe you're listening with kids, it's at our website.
友情提示：本播客未对脏话进行消音处理。如果您更喜欢消音版，或者是在有孩子的情况下收听，请前往我们的网站。
He was saying all types, like things hurry the f-- hurry the fuck up, move the fuck on, get out of his fucking face. He would try to get free things. So he would, like, threaten them. Like, oh, I'm not going to let you through if you don't give me free food. And they would give him water and juices and stuff. So it's like he was extorting them, basically. Yeah.
他什么都说，比如“快点，他妈的快点”，“赶紧滚开”，“离他妈的远点”。他还试图索要免费的东西。他会威胁他们，比如，哦，如果你不给我免费的食物，我就不让你通过。他们只好给他水、果汁之类的东西。所以这基本上就是敲诈。是的。
He kept telling me he was a Russian badass. That's what he kept saying. He was like, I'm a Russian badass. And he had-- it was like a baseball cap flipped backwards. We're supposed to wear it forward, with the-- and he flipped it backwards, and he opened his shirt, and he was saying, I'm a Russian bad boy. You know I'm a badass, right? And I was like, I have no idea who you are. Today's my first day, I don't know who this guy is. He's freaking me out already.
他一直告诉我他是个俄罗斯硬汉。他反复这么说。他说，我是个俄罗斯硬汉。他戴着一顶反戴的棒球帽。我们本应把帽檐朝前戴，但他把它反过来了，他还敞开衬衫，说，我是个俄罗斯坏小子。你知道我是个硬汉，对吧？我说，我根本不知道你是谁。今天是我第一天上班，我不知道这家伙是谁。他已经把我吓坏了。
After checking cargo vans and trucks for a while, the guy told LaDonna that he was going to be inside the security booth by himself for a bit. She should stay outside by herself and wait. He played music in the booth and started looking at what LaDonna says was a Playboy magazine. LaDonna had read the employee handbook and knew that both of those things were a violation of company policy. And she had also read a book that her best friend gave her, Nice Girls Don't Get the Corner Office. And she thought of it now, the way that guy dismissed her, treated her like, you know, a girl.
在检查货车和卡车一段时间后，那个人告诉LaDonna，他要一个人在安保亭里待一会儿。让她自己留在外面等。他在亭子里放音乐，还开始看LaDonna所说的那种《花花公子》杂志。LaDonna读过员工手册，知道这两项行为都违反了公司规定。她还读过好友送她的书《好女孩进不了转角办公室》。她现在想到了这一点，那个家伙轻视她、把她当成“女孩”对待的方式。
Like I'm overly nice and easy to walk over. Like, OK.
就像我很软弱，容易被欺负。好吧。
Wrong. Nice Girls Don't Get the Corner Office spends a lot of time on not being easy to walk over, on the need to speak up, on the need to stand up for yourself. LaDonna reads lots of these business books and management and self-help books. She watches talks online-- not for motivation. She is so motivated, in general, one of her friends calls her Olivia Pope-- like, always wanting to fix something.
错了。《好女孩进不了转角办公室》花了很多篇幅讲不要轻易受人摆布，要勇于发言，要坚持立场。LaDonna读了很多商业、管理和励志书籍。她还在网上看讲座——不是为了激励，她本身就很有动力。她的一个朋友称她为“奥利维亚·波普”（Olivia Pope）——总是想要解决问题。
She reads this stuff because the worldview in these books matches the way that LaDonna already sees things. Like, they give her words to describe what she is feeling all the time anyway-- always try to elevate, always be moving ahead. And this dude, disrespecting his job and her, he was an affront to that entire worldview. So even though it was her very first day out in the field doing her brand-new job, right then, on the tarmac, she decided she had to confront the problem.
她读这些书是因为书中的世界观与LaDonna原本的看法相符。它们给了她描述自己感受的词汇——总是试图提升，总是不断前进。而这个家伙，不尊重工作，也不尊重她，是对她整个世界观的侮辱。所以，尽管这是她到现场开展新工作的第一天，就在那一刻，在停机坪上，她决定必须面对这个问题。
So I was riding back with him in the car, and I said to him, why do you do things like that at work? And he was just like, he hates the job. He was like, he hated that place, and that's just what he does. He does whatever he wants to do. And I was like, well, you know, you make it bad for everyone else. If you don't want to be here, just don't come. And then he started calling me, like, Sister Souljah, and then he made a joke about it. And that was it.
我和他一起开车回去时，问他，为什么在工作时要那样做？他只是说，他讨厌这份工作。他说，他讨厌那个地方，这就是他的行事风格。他想干什么就干什么。我说，好吧，但你让其他人都很难做。如果你不想待在这，就别来。然后他开始叫我“苏贾修女”（Sister Souljah），还开了一个玩笑。事情就是这样。
She was not diminished. LaDonna had no respect for a person who did not value this place or this job. And when they got back to the supervisor's office-- LaDonna did not feel great about this, but she told a supervisor about the Russian badass and his behavior. In other words, she handled it. Spoke her mind to the dude, check. Reported him, check. He did not get to her, check and checkmate. And eventually-- she explained this to our producer, Chana Joffe-Walt, who was the one who actually talked to her-- she explained that the Russian badass, he got fired-- for something totally unrelated, actually.
她没有被吓倒。LaDonna对这种不珍惜这里或这份工作的人毫无敬意。回到主管办公室后，LaDonna虽然心里不舒服，但还是向主管报告了那个“俄罗斯硬汉”的行为。换句话说，她处理了这件事。当面说出了自己的想法，搞定；举报了他，搞定。他没能影响她，完胜。最终——她向我们的制作人Chana Joffe-Walt解释道，是Chana亲自和她谈的——她解释说那个俄罗斯硬汉被解雇了——其实是因为一件完全无关的事。
He stole water from Port Authority, and they fired him.
他从港务局偷水，他们就开除了他。
What do you mean he stole water?
你说他偷水是什么意思？
The water coolers, how they have-- he would take them out of the storage and put them in the trunk of his car.
饮水机用的那种水，他从仓库里拿出来，放进自己车的后备箱里。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And they caught him-- exactly. And they caught him.
他们抓到了他——没错。他们抓到了他。
Those jugs that go in a water cooler?
就是那种放在饮水机上的大桶水？
Yes. They had him on CC camera going to his car with the water, because he's a badass. He probably walked out with it on his head and carried it to the car.
是的。闭路电视拍到他搬着水去车上，因为他是个“硬汉”。他可能顶着水桶走出去，然后搬到车里。
So he got fired for stealing water, not for looking at pornography while he was on the job?
所以他是因为偷水被开除的，而不是因为在工作时看色情内容？
Right. Yeah.
对。是的。
Dude likes water.
这家伙还真是喜欢水。
Yeah, exactly. Clearly.
是的，没错。显而易见。
LaDonna Powell is not a Russian badass. She's a totally different kind of badass. It's like she's a dedicated student of how to be a great employee, the kind of employee who excels and rises in an organization. And now she was entering a company that would be the greatest sort of challenge for an employee like that, a place where people are not playing by the rules. The Russian was just the very first obstacle she faced. It was about to get way uglier.
LaDonna Powell不是什么俄罗斯硬汉。她是另一种硬汉。她是一个如何成为优秀员工的勤奋学生，那种在组织中出类拔萃、不断晋升的员工。现在，她进入了一家对这样的员工来说是最大挑战的公司，一个人们不按规矩办事的地方。那个俄罗斯人只是她面临的第一个障碍。事情只会变得更糟糕。
What you're about to hear is the story of a willful and principled person who sets out to figure out, first, how to rise in this company and, second, how to remake the way the entire place runs, which requires some ingenious strategizing on her part. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
你即将听到的是一个意志坚定且有原则的人的故事，她决心先弄清楚如何在这家公司晋升，其次是如何重塑整个地方的运营方式，这需要她运用一些巧妙的策略。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, The Old Guard. Well, Chana Joffe-Walt has been talking to LaDonna, plus lots of other people at Allied Universal at JFK, for months, and now she's going to take over telling LaDonna's story. Just a heads up that there is provocative language and content in here that might not be right for every listener. Here's Chana.
第一幕，旧势力。Chana Joffe-Walt几个月来一直与LaDonna以及肯尼迪机场Allied Universal的许多其他人交谈，现在她将接手讲述LaDonna的故事。请注意，内容中可能包含一些挑衅性的语言和内容，可能不适合所有听众。请听Chana的讲述。
When you board a plane, sit down, and look out the window, you see the guys throwing the bags, and then, beyond that, just concrete expanse. That's where LaDonna worked. That's where the Allied guards are, stationed in booths along the tarmac. The booths are basically checkpoints for everything that goes out there-- food, fuel, water, duty-free purses. The booths are about the size of a U-Haul trailer, metal and steel with big glass windows.
当你登机坐下向窗外看时，你会看到搬运工人在扔行李，再远一点就是混凝土空地。那就是LaDonna工作的地方。那里有Allied的保安，驻扎在停机坪沿线的岗亭里。岗亭基本上是所有出入物资的检查站——食物、燃料、水、免税包包。岗亭大约有一个U-Haul拖车那么大，是金属和钢材结构的，有巨大的玻璃窗。
At the beginning of each eight-hour shift, LaDonna would go to the Allied locker room, change, and stand in line for roll call outside the supervisor's office. Then the supervisor would tell her which posts she had that day out on the tarmac, and she'd head out there to a booth in the pavement. The guard she was relieving would drive away. Trucks would come by. She would check for bombs, drugs, food packages to see if anything was open. And she would wait-- lots of waiting.
每八小时轮班开始时，LaDonna会去Allied的更衣室换衣服，然后在主管办公室外排队点名。主管会告诉她今天在停机坪的哪个岗位，她就会前往岗亭。接替她的保安会开车离开。卡车会过来。她要检查炸弹、毒品、食品包裹，看看有没有被打开过。然后就是等待——漫长的等待。
Occasionally, a supervisor would come by to check on her. One night, it was an older, gruff supervisor named Kevin McNamara. LaDonna says he came in to her booth--
偶尔，主管会过来查看她。一天晚上，来了一位粗鲁的老主管Kevin McNamara。LaDonna说他进了她的岗亭——
And he asked me to open my jacket. And he took his phone out to take a photo of me. And I was like, excuse me. He was like, open your jacket and turn around. And I was like, I'm not.
他让我打开外套。还掏出手机要给我拍照。我说，不好意思。他说，打开外套转一圈。我说，我不。
And he tried to say, oh, I'm just taking a picture of you. The company has a policy where we take a photo of you. And I remember reading it when they gave us a handbook, and I said, no, you're supposed to take a picture of my outside, my outer garment. And he's like, no, you're going to open your coat and turn around. He was so abrupt and aggressive with me-- just, you're going to do what I say. Like, you're going to turn around, you're going to do what I say, and that's it. And I was like, that has nothing to do with the job.
他试图说，哦，我只是在给你拍照。公司有规定要拍你的照片。我记得在他们发手册时读到过，我说，不，你们应该拍的是我的外侧，也就是外衣。他说，不，你要打开外套转一圈。他对我非常生硬和咄咄逼人——就是，你必须按我说的做。就像，你得转一圈，你得听我的，就这样。我说，这跟工作毫无关系。
The job was to guard the post. LaDonna felt like Kevin wanted a show. LaDonna is small, just under 5 feet tall. Her resting position is almost always perfect posture, standing at attention, hands clasped at her belt, elbows out. The booth was a very tight space for two people.
这份工作是守岗。LaDonna觉得Kevin想要看表演。LaDonna个子小，不到5英尺高。她平时总保持着完美的站姿，立正，双手交叠在皮带上，手肘向外。岗亭对两个人来说是非常狭小的空间。
And I was like, you're going to get the fuck out of my face. Like, I'm not turning around, and I know that's not what you're supposed to be doing, and I'm not supposed to open my clothes for you. And he told me, oh, if I didn't listen, he was going to make it hard. He's like, you always have something to say. You always have something to say.
我说，你给我离远点。我不会转圈，我知道那不是你应该做的，我也不应该为你打开衣服。他告诉我，如果不听话，他会让我很难做。他说，你总是那么多话。你总是那么多话。
But then he dropped it. He drove away. LaDonna took note. Success-- she drew a line, and he backed down.
但随后他作罢了。他开车离开了。LaDonna记下了。成功了——她划定了一条底线，他退缩了。
JFK airport covers 5,000 acres. There are approximately 300 Allied guards. LaDonna met some of her coworkers in the locker room before and after shifts. That's where she learned that one of the worst posts was called Post Hotel. It got the most traffic. Second worst was Post Papa. It was distant and remote, though I don't think that's how it got its name. LaDonna noted that nobody wanted these posts, and she also noticed that she started to be assigned them, shift after shift.
肯尼迪机场占地5000英亩。大约有300名Allied保安。LaDonna在更衣室遇到了她的一些同事。她在那里得知，最差的岗位叫“酒店岗”。那里人流量最大。第二差的是“爸爸岗”。它偏远，虽然我不认为这就是它得名的原因。LaDonna注意到没人想要这些岗位，也注意到她开始被反复指派到这些岗位，班次接上班次。
You feel forgotten, in a way, almost, because how do you go to the bathroom? How do you-- you can't do anything. You're just there. At first, it was like, OK, solitude, you know? But then it's like, all right, are you guys coming to relieve me? Can I go to the ba-- can I eat something? Am I going to get to go home? Sometimes, you'll be stuck there 12 hours. They'll forget to send you a relief.
你会有种被遗忘的感觉，因为怎么上厕所？怎么……你什么都做不了。你就在那。起初，感觉就像是，好吧，独处，你知道吗？但后来就会想，好吧，你们打算来接班吗？我能去……我能吃点东西吗？我能回家吗？有时，你会连续待上12个小时。他们忘了派人来接你。
There are cameras in the booths so supervisors in the main office can check on their guards. Of course, she couldn't see the supervisor's office, but they could see her. Were they watching her? When she did get a response on the radio, the supervisor would say they didn't have anyone available to relieve her. She'd squirm, needing to go to the bathroom. Did they see that?
岗亭里有摄像头，主管办公室的主管可以查看保安的情况。当然，她看不到主管办公室，但他们能看到她。他们在监视她吗？当她通过对讲机得到回应时，主管会说没人能接替她。她急得想上厕所。他们看到了吗？
Most nights, Kevin was her tour supervisor. He worked in the supervisor's office with the other supervisor on duty. Sometimes he'd drive around to check on people. She'd wonder, are they're busy? Are they not there? Or maybe--
大多数晚上，Kevin是她的巡视主管。他和当班的另一位主管在主管办公室工作。有时他会开车四处巡视。她会想，他们很忙吗？他们不在吗？或者……
Are they picking on me? Am I not getting to go to the bathroom because I spoke up? Am I not getting a lunch break, are my hours being cut because I spoke up about what's happening? And I would always have these thoughts, are they doing this because I keep talking back?
他们是在针对我吗？是因为我说了话才不让我去厕所吗？是因为我说了话，我的午休被取消、工作时间被削减了吗？我总是会有这些想法，他们这么做是因为我不断回嘴吗？
When traffic was low, LaDonna would sometimes take out her reading, and suddenly a voice would come into the booth, put that away. Or when she'd eat, no eating in the booth. So they were there. But then, silence for hours. As families took off in planes above her for Florida and business people came in from Dubai, LaDonna was stuck in a box below, amid 5,000 acres of pavement.
当交通量较小时，LaDonna有时会拿出书来读，突然对讲机里传来一个声音，收起来。或者当她吃东西时，说不准在岗亭里吃。所以他们一直在那里。但随后又是数小时的沉默。当一家家人的飞机从她上方起飞前往佛罗里达，商务人士从迪拜抵达时，LaDonna被困在下面一个盒子里，置身于5000英亩的停机坪中。
In the locker room, another guard told LaDonna, there's a corner of the booth where they can't see you. The cameras don't reach there. They can only see your feet. So LaDonna started packing peanut butter and jelly triangles and standing in that corner to eat them. Sometimes that would work. Sometimes she'd hear the supervisor, Kevin's voice suddenly, come forward in front of the camera.
在更衣室里，另一名保安告诉LaDonna，岗亭有一个角落他们看不到。摄像头够不到那里。他们只能看到你的脚。于是LaDonna开始带花生酱果酱三明治，站在那个角落吃。有时管用。有时她会突然听到主管Kevin的声音，让她到摄像头前面来。
And I kept trying to understand, what am I doing wrong with my interactions with him? Because someone else tried to tell me, oh, he's nice to this girl. She's Spanish. It's not because you're black. I--
我一直试图理解，我和他的互动到底哪里做错了？因为有人试图告诉我，哦，他对那个女孩很友善。她是西班牙裔。不是因为你是黑人。我……
He's a white guy?
他是白人吗？
He's an older white man. It's something else. And I said, OK, maybe my approach is wrong with him. So I didn't know how to manage him. He was just-- he would have these outbursts.
他是位上了年纪的白人。这是别的原因。我说，好吧，也许我对他的方式不对。我不知道该如何应付他。他只是……他会突然发火。
He would always say, oh, he's management, and we're not like him, and he's better than the rest of us because he gets an expense card and he wears the blazer. He can do what he wants. Oh, I've been here for years. It's like, how do you manage that? How do I correct you?
他总是说，哦，他是管理层，我们和他不一样，他比我们剩下的人都强，因为他有报销卡，还穿西装。他可以想干什么就干什么。哦，我在这里工作很多年了。就像，怎么对付这种人？我该怎么纠正你？
Kevin McNamara did not want to talk to us for this story. LaDonna says it was around this time that she started to repeat phrases to herself from the book Managing Your Manager by Gonzague Dufour. It lays out three strategies for handling a bully boss. Number one, don't take it personally. Two, find the humor. And three, most important, limit the pain, target the game. Done correctly, you build skills, you level up, and you move on to a place where you'll get a better boss. View the bully as temporary.
Kevin McNamara拒绝接受我们的采访。LaDonna说，大约从那时起，她开始对自己重复Gonzague Dufour所著《管理你的经理》中的名句。书中提出了处理霸道老板的三种策略。第一，不要个人化。第二，寻找幽默感。第三，也是最重要的一点，限制痛苦，锁定目标。操作得当，你会积累技能，升级，然后跳槽到有更好老板的地方。把霸道老板视为暂时的。
This is how she would correct Kevin-- do her job extremely well, get through this part, and be seen by the people above Kevin. She'd repeat to herself, everyone has a boss. And it was that boss-- Kevin's boss-- she was focused on. At the worst post, on the worst shift, without breaks, LaDonna targeted the game. It was busy, lots of opportunities for growth.
这就是她纠正Kevin的方式——把工作做到极致，熬过这一段，被Kevin之上的人看到。她对自己重复，每个人都有老板。而她关注的正是那个老板——Kevin的老板。在最差的岗位、最差的班次，没有休息时间，LaDonna锁定了目标。那里很忙，有很大的成长机会。
I really learned a lot, just working out there. You're outside in the field, so it's very hands-on. You're using a mirror, you're checking under vehicles for bombs, you're checking under vehicles for any anomalies, anything that's not supposed to be there, just making sure when it goes on the runway that it's safe. So it felt good, purposeful. Like, OK, I'm actually doing something.
我在外面工作确实学到了很多。你在现场，所以非常务实。你需要用镜子，检查车辆下是否有炸弹，检查车辆下是否有任何异常，任何不该在那里的东西，只是确保在进入跑道时它是安全的。所以感觉很好，很有目标感。就像，好吧，我真的在做点什么。
This appeared to go unseen by Kevin. Everyone has a boss, she'd tell herself, but she never heard from Kevin's boss. What continued to be noticed was her failure to put her body where the supervisors could see it. She'd hear their voices in the booth, telling her to come forward in front of the camera. When she worked hard, nothing. When she needed a bathroom relief after 8 or 10 or sometimes 12 hours, no answer. So she'd limit the pain. On her way to work--
Kevin似乎没看到这一点。每个人都有老板，她对自己说，但她从未收到Kevin老板的反馈。他们继续关注的是她未能将身体置于主管能看到的地方。她会在岗亭里听到他们的声音，叫她站到摄像头前面。她努力工作时，没人理。当她工作8或10甚至12小时后需要上厕所时，没人应答。所以她会限制痛苦。在上班路上——
I would go to the-- there was a convenience store on Lefferts Boulevard before I got there, and I would go to the convenience store. I would get a juice or ask for a coffee and get an extra cup on the bottom of it.
我会去……在到那之前，Lefferts大道上有一家便利店，我会去那里。我会买果汁或要杯咖啡，在杯子底下再放一个空杯。
In the locker room, before her shift, LaDonna would throw in the cup with the rest of her stuff for when she had to pee. She'd head to roll call, with Kevin.
在更衣室，轮班前，LaDonna会把这个杯子和她的其他东西放在一起，以备她需要尿尿时使用。她去点名，和Kevin在一起。
And I would be there. I would have a roll of tissue-- like, I'd roll it up on my hand in the locker room-- and an empty cup with me all night. Oh, and that was another thing. He would come and look at your bag, because you have a clear plastic bag. They want to make sure you're not carrying any electronics out there onto the field, or you're not stealing anything. So you have a transparent bag. OK, fine.
我就在那。我会带一卷纸巾——在更衣室里卷在手上——还有个空杯子和我一起待一整晚。哦，还有件事。他会过来检查你的包，因为你有一个透明塑料袋。他们想确保你没有带任何电子产品到现场，或者没有偷任何东西。所以你有一个透明袋。好吧，行。
You can see straight through my bag, but then he still would make comments about my pads and my tampon-- oh, why do you need so many pads? It's like, why do you care? It doesn't bother you, and clearly you can see that it's not something I stole from here, so why do you care?
你可以直接看穿我的包，但他还是会对我的卫生巾和卫生棉条发表评论——哦，你为什么需要这么多卫生巾？这就像，你关心这个干嘛？这又不打扰你，而且很明显这不是我从这偷的，所以你关心这个干嘛？
Everyone has a boss, she told herself.
每个人都有老板，她对自己说。
Don't go back at him. Tone it down and say, OK. Just try to focus on me. How can I get past this stage?
不要回嘴。压低声音说，好的。尽量专注于我自己。我该如何度过这个阶段？
LaDonna stuck to her plan, did her job extremely well, worked hard. And then, just as the book said, she was noticed-- not by Kevin or his boss but by a manager at the airport. This man had seen LaDonna working, seen how hard she worked, and he recommended to Allied that they promote LaDonna to supervisor. This recommendation likely carried weight-- the airport is Allied's client-- and it definitely had an effect on LaDonna. She'd never even thought about being a supervisor. That was many levels above what she'd imagined.
LaDonna坚持她的计划，工作非常出色，非常努力。然后，正如那本书所说，她被注意到了——不是被Kevin或他的老板，而是被机场的一位经理。这个人看到LaDonna在工作，看到她有多努力，于是建议Allied将LaDonna提升为主管。这个建议可能很有分量——机场是Allied的客户——这对LaDonna确实产生了影响。她甚至从未想过要当主管。那比她想象的级别高多了。
And then she read Lean In. Lean In is by Sheryl Sandberg, the COO of Facebook. It explains why so few women make it to the top of their professions. Sandberg argues that women-- and this is the line LaDonna slowed down on-- women systematically underestimate their abilities. LaDonna had been so focused on her bosses underestimating her abilities, maybe she had underestimated herself. Now she'd been noticed. Someone saw her as supervisor material. She just had to answer one question for herself, the question posed by Sheryl Sandberg, one of the most powerful female executives in the world-- could she picture herself as a boss?
然后她读了《向前一步》（Lean In）。《向前一步》的作者是Facebook首席运营官谢丽尔·桑德伯格。它解释了为什么很少有女性能做到职业生涯的顶峰。桑德伯格认为女性——LaDonna在这一行停了下来——女性系统性地低估了自己的能力。LaDonna一直专注于她的老板低估她的能力，也许她低估了自己。现在她被注意到了。有人认为她是主管人选。她只需要为自己回答一个问题，这个问题由世界上最强大的女性高管之一谢丽尔·桑德伯格提出——她能想象自己当老板吗？
It was like, do I really want to be in charge of other people? And then I have to take a step back and say, do I really want these kind of people in charge of me? It's like, I never had that moment until then. These are the guys in charge of me? I'm peeing in a cup outside. These are the people in charge of me. So I really had to evaluate what I was doing-- what I was doing mentally to myself. Like, I was literally my biggest enemy.
就像，我真的想负责管理其他人吗？然后我必须退后一步说，我真的想让这种人管我吗？就像，在那之前我从未有过这种时刻。这些人是管我的？我在外面用杯子尿尿。这些人是管我的。所以我真的必须评估我在做什么——我在精神上对自己做了什么。就像，我真的是我最大的敌人。
That voice in the booth, the unseen authority that LaDonna had found so unnerving, suddenly seemed ridiculous. Why is he counting her pads? Why can't she just eat her PB and J? They seemed desperate and threatened.
岗亭里的那个声音，LaDonna觉得令人不安的那个隐形权威，突然显得很可笑。他为什么要数她的卫生巾？她为什么不能吃她的花生酱三明治？他们看起来绝望又受到威胁。
I can do the job you're doing. You're not Jesus right now because you're a supervisor. I can read and execute this job just like you, if not better, because all you're doing is acting like Adolf Hitler, an insane person here, and you're treating people like animals. Let's try the other way.
我能做你做的工作。你现在不是耶稣，因为你是主管。我能读懂并执行这份工作，就像你一样，甚至更好，因为你所做的只是像阿道夫·希特勒，一个精神病患者一样在这里行事，把人当动物对待。让我们换种方式。
After two years at Allied, LaDonna made it to supervisor. She went from $15 an hour as a guard to $32 an hour. And in June 2014, she entered the supervisor's office.
在Allied工作两年后，LaDonna晋升为主管。她的时薪从15美元涨到了32美元。2014年6月，她进入了主管办公室。
I get to walk in, and now they're going to see me in my blue shirt-- because the supervisors wear a different blue shirt from the security guards-- and I was like, oh, they're going to piss their pants. They're going to be so pissed off because now I'm equal. We're both in the same field. We're both in the same position. You won't call me a bitch. You won't do that because now, possibly, you might view me as an equal.
我走进去，现在他们会在我穿着蓝色衬衫时看到我——因为主管穿的蓝色衬衫与安保人员不同——我想，哦，他们会吓尿的。他们会气疯的，因为现在我是平等的。我们都在同一个领域。我们都在同一个职位。你不会叫我婊子。你不会那样做，因为现在，可能，你会视我为平等的。
The supervisor's office was about the size of a large bedroom, an open space with three desks, computers, a printer-copier machine, and schedules all over the walls. There were about 12 other supervisors, different races, mostly men. They worked in shifts of two. LaDonna met her new boss-- Kevin's boss, the boss of all the supervisors-- a tall black man named Chris Timberlake. And she was given 50-something guards of her own to manage each shift, guards who needed schedules and overtime arrangements and to be counted at the beginning and end of every shift. She managed payroll and drove the premises to check on the guard booths. She went to daily supervisor briefings. Every part felt urgent and exciting, especially the meetings, where they talked strategy.
主管办公室大约有一间大卧室那么大，是一个开阔的空间，有三张桌子、电脑、一台打印复印机，墙上贴满了时间表。还有大约12位其他主管，不同种族，大多是男性。他们两人一组轮班。LaDonna见到了她的新老板——Kevin的老板，所有主管的老板——一位名叫Chris Timberlake的黑人高个子。她被分配了50多名保安供她在每个班次管理，这些保安需要排班、加班安排，并且需要在每个班次开始和结束时点名。她负责工资发放，开车巡视岗亭。她参加主管每日简报。每一部分都让人感到紧迫和兴奋，尤其是会议，他们在会上讨论战略。
Sometimes I can't wait for them to finish a sentence. I just jump in. I said, sometimes, I feel like they're thinking slower than me.
有时我迫不及待地想让他们说完一句话。我就直接插进去。我说，有时，我觉得他们思考得比我慢。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Like maybe they're still figuring it out, and I'm already at the end point. And I'm like, well, that's not going to work.
就像他们可能还在摸索，而我已经到了终点。我说，好吧，那行不通。
LaDonna had new ideas. She was nice, but not too nice, assertive, but deferential to her boss Chris Timberlake, bringing things to him first. Like, one time, she went to his office across the hall--
LaDonna有新想法。她很友善，但不太软弱；很自信，但对她的老板Chris Timberlake毕恭毕敬，先和他沟通。比如，有一次，她去了走廊对面的办公室——
And I said to him, we have a training class. I'm just talking to him-- now, I'm a supervisor at this time-- and he's like, come here, come around the desk for a second. I want to show you something on the computer. I'm like, OK, what's going on?
我对他说，我们要上培训课。我只是在和他说话——那时我是主管——他说，过来，到桌子这边来一下。我想在电脑上给你看点东西。我说，好吧，怎么了？
So I come around to look. I'm like, hey-- and it's women pole dancing, and they're, like, licking on each other in a strip club and pole dancing. He's like, can you do this? And he's calling the other male sup-- come here, come here, let me show you what I'm showing Powell. And they're both showing it to me. He's like, yeah, I seen that. I seen that on YouTube. It's crazy, right? Powell, you could do that, right? You could do that? You do that at home?
我走过去看。我说，嘿——那是女人在跳钢管舞，她们在脱衣舞俱乐部里互相舔舐，跳着钢管舞。他说，你能这样吗？他还叫其他男主管过来，过来，看看我给Powell看的东西。他们都在给我看。他说，是啊，我看了。我在YouTube上看的。太疯狂了，对吧？Powell，你能那样，对吧？你能那样吗？你在家里那样吗？
In LaDonna's head, she's Sheryl Sandberg right here. They were imagining her in a porn show, pole dancing.
在LaDonna脑海里，她现在就是谢丽尔·桑德伯格。他们把她想象成在色情表演中跳钢管舞。
And I was like, you know what? Fuck the both of you. And I just walked out. I just walked out. I was like, you two are the worst, the worst type of people. I walked out.
我说，你知道吗？去你们俩的。我直接走了出去。我就是走了出去。我说，你们两个是最坏的，最糟糕的人。我走了出去。
Did you say that to them, or did you just--
你对他们说了吗，还是你只是……
I said that to them, and they just laughed me off. They laughed me off.
我对他们说了，他们只是把我当作笑话。他们只是嘲笑我。
So it wasn't just Kevin. It was Kevin's boss too-- Chris Timberlake, who was now her boss. He told LaDonna, you have nice lips, made comments about her body. When she'd go to the copier, he'd come up behind her and push into her. Chris Timberlake, like Kevin McNamara, did not want to talk to us for this story. LaDonna says she'd come in to work to find other supervisors gathered around someone's phone, watching videos of people having sex. They'd invite her over and ask her if she could do it like that.
所以不只是Kevin。还有Kevin的老板——Chris Timberlake，他现在是她的老板。他告诉LaDonna，你有漂亮的嘴唇，还对她的身体发表评论。当她去复印时，他会走到她身后蹭她。Chris Timberlake和Kevin McNamara一样，拒绝接受我们的采访。LaDonna说，她上班时会发现其他主管围在某人的手机旁，看着人们做爱的视频。他们会叫她过去，问她能不能那样做。
LaDonna surveilled the supervisors in the same way they used to surveil her. She studied how they operated and just how closely they watched the women who worked there. Like with one guard, Marsha-Nique Irving.
LaDonna以他们曾经监视她的方式监视着这些主管。她研究他们的运作方式，以及他们监视在那里工作的女性的程度。比如有个保安，Marsha-Nique Irving。
She would change her hair often or her makeup often, and they would make sexual comments about it.
她经常换发型或换妆容，他们会对此发表性评论。
Like what?
比如什么？
Like, oh, you saw Marsha-Nique? Her titties look good today, and she got her hair done. Or she would change her lashes-- like, they were longer. Like, oh, she got porno-star lashes, things like that. And she would always brush them off. And she was very feisty, and I loved that-- I loved to watch her answer them. And it was like, good for you. You know? It was like, good for you.
比如，哦，你看到Marsha-Nique了吗？她今天的乳房看起来不错，她还做了头发。或者她换了睫毛——比如，更长了。比如，哦，她做了色情明星睫毛，之类的。她总是把这些当耳旁风。她非常有活力，我喜欢这一点——我喜欢看她回应他们。感觉就像，做得好。你知道吗？就像，做得好。
LaDonna was working one night, and she heard Marsha-Nique radio in to her supervisor, Osvaldo Ortiz-- everyone called him Ozzie. LaDonna was doing paperwork. Ozzie was sitting with another male supervisor, monitoring the guard radios. And Marsha-Nique radioed to say she needed bathroom relief.
有一天晚上LaDonna在上班，听到Marsha-Nique用对讲机呼叫她的主管Osvaldo Ortiz——大家都叫他Ozzie。LaDonna正在处理文书工作。Ozzie和另一位男主管坐在一起，监控着保安对讲机。Marsha-Nique用对讲机说她需要上厕所。
And I watched him tell her four times, oh, give me a few minutes. I'm trying to find somebody. They were never trying to find somebody. Never once did they call anybody else, ask anybody else, check a sheet to see if you had somebody else. The two men that were in there was like, fuck her, she always talking shit, fuck her. And it made me look up, because I was doing paperwork. And I turned, and I was like, this is what they were saying about me when I was asking to use the bathroom. And it was so much validation. My assumptions were validated. It was like, wow, this is really what you guys are doing.
我看着他四次告诉她，哦，给我几分钟。我正试着找人。他们根本没想找人。他们从未呼叫过别人，问过别人，查看过有没有人可以替班。屋里的那两个男的就像是，去他妈的，她总是废话多，去他妈的。这让我抬头看，因为我当时在做文书。我转过身，心想，这就是我申请上厕所时他们说的话。这简直是太多的验证了。我的猜想被验证了。就像，哇，这就是你们这些家伙在做的事。
This went on for hours. LaDonna didn't say anything at first. She just watched, as Marsha-Nique radioed again.
这种情况持续了几个小时。LaDonna起初什么也没说。她只是看着，听着Marsha-Nique再次呼叫。
Calling to go to the bathroom-- and she said to them, I have my period. You could tell she was already hesitant to say it, because she's saying it on a live stream. Not only can all of us hear it-- which is like 57 radios of people-- now you're making her say that, and the client can also hear her. So that's our 57 radios and eight radios Port Authority in Manhattan and Port Authority in JFK can hear.
呼叫去厕所——她对他们说，我来月经了。你能看出她本来就很犹豫要不要说，因为她是在直播频道说的。不仅我们所有人都能听到——大约有57个对讲机的人——现在你让她说那个，客户也能听到她。所以这是我们的57个对讲机，加上曼哈顿和肯尼迪机场港务局的8个对讲机都能听到。
Embarrassing. She ended up using the bathroom on herself and bleeding on herself that day. Nothing, no sorry. They were all laughing about it, thought it was hilarious. Oh, she going to sit in her piss until she gets off. Like, they had no concern for her.
太尴尬了。那天她最终尿在身上，经血也流在身上。什么也没有，一句道歉都没有。他们都在嘲笑，觉得这很有趣。哦，她会坐在自己的尿里直到下班。就像，他们对她毫无关心。
The supervisor, Ozzie, did not want to talk to us. I did talk to Marsha-Nique. She describes this the same way LaDonna does. But of course, at the time, Marsha-Nique couldn't see what was happening in the supervisor's office, the things LaDonna was now seeing clearly.
主管Ozzie拒绝接受我们的采访。我和Marsha-Nique谈过。她描述的情况和LaDonna一样。但当然，那时Marsha-Nique看不到主管办公室里正在发生什么，看不到LaDonna现在看得一清二楚的事。
I'm not just paranoid. This is in stereo. Because seriously, I really was like, OK, maybe you're just paranoid. And then you get in the office, and it's like, oh, no. They're disgusting.
我不只是多疑。这是立体声的。因为说真的，我以前真的会想，好吧，也许你只是多疑。然后你进了办公室，就是，哦，不。他们真恶心。
It's just disgusting. This is what you're doing at work-- at work. I think they need a shirt that says "At Work." Maybe they don't get it. We are at work.
这真是太恶心了。这就是你们在工作时做的事——在工作时。我觉得他们需要一件写着“在工作”的衬衫。也许他们不明白。我们在工作。
It's just like a little T-shirt reminder.
就像一件小T恤提醒一下。
Right. Every time they start to do it, they're like, oh, wait, at work. Yes, you're at work.
对。每次他们开始做这事时，他们就会想，哦，等等，在工作。是的，你在工作。
Being at work means something specific to LaDonna, something she assumes is universal but not everyone feels. To her, you're at work. It's almost like saying you're at church. You're supposed to be your best and look out for others.
在LaDonna看来，在工作意味着具体的东西，一些她认为是普遍但并非每个人都有所感的东西。对她来说，你在工作。就像说你在教堂一样。你应该做到最好，照顾他人。
In Lean In, Sheryl Sandberg tells a story. When she was pregnant-- she was working at Google-- it was the early years of the company. And she was late for a meeting. She had to park way far out. The company was growing so fast, there was no parking close by.
在《向前一步》中，谢丽尔·桑德伯格讲了一个故事。她怀孕时——在谷歌工作——那是公司成立早期。她开会迟到了。她不得不停在很远的地方。公司发展太快，附近没有停车位。
And after running, with a big belly, to get to her meeting, Sandberg marched in to speak with Sergey Brin and Larry Page, the founders of Google. We need pregnancy parking, she said. Oh, they said. Sure, of course. They just never thought of it before.
在挺着大肚子跑去开会后，桑德伯格大步走进办公室，去见谷歌创始人谢尔盖·布林和拉里·佩奇。我们需要孕妇停车位，她说。哦，他们说。当然，没问题。他们只是以前从未想过。
Sandberg writes, "That is the power of being in the room. The other pregnant women must have suffered in silence. Having one pregnant woman at the top made the difference." That was the power LaDonna felt she had, in the room, when Marsha-Nique called in. And she used it.
桑德伯格写道：“这就是身处其中的力量。其他怀孕的女性一定在默默承受。有一位怀孕的女性身居高位，结果就不同了。”这就是LaDonna在Marsha-Nique呼叫时，作为办公室一员所感到的力量。她利用了这一点。
And when I said it to them, the first time-- like, so she's not going to get to go to the bathroom? No, I'm not going to send that relief over there for her. She'll figure it out. How? There's nowhere for her to go. She's not a-- she can't just pull her penis out and pee in the woods. And then he just-- he was like, this is what she's calling for? And I'm like, you get a period?
当我第一次对他们说时——就像，所以她不能去厕所？不，我不会派替班去那。她自己会想办法的。怎么想？她没地方去。她又不是……她不能在大森林里掏出阴茎尿尿。然后他只是……他就像，她就为了这个呼叫？我说，你来过月经吗？
And he looks at me. I'm like, you tell me if you get a period, if you know exactly-- a woman doesn't want to keep a pad on more than four hours. And it's that kind of thing that I just wanted to be in the room to be able to say-- consider this person, consider them as a person.
他看着我。我说，你告诉我你是否来过月经，如果你完全了解……一个女人不想把卫生巾戴超过四小时。正是那种事，我只想在房间里能够说——考虑一下这个人，把她们当一个人来考虑。
Consider this person-- that is what LaDonna's presence was supposed to do, to induce empathy, the kind of consideration she had wanted from her boss, Kevin, when she was out in the field. LaDonna put herself in the supervisor's room with him, made him see her-- blue shirt, just like him. But LaDonna says when she came in as supervisor, Kevin's response was not to consider her. She says his response was, wow, they must have been scraping the bottom of the barrel to bring you in. LaDonna says Kevin would violate protocol and change the schedule without regard to people's medical needs. LaDonna would correct him. Consider this person. When he told the LaDonna to change the payroll so they wouldn't have to pay one of the guards overtime he was owed, LaDonna held onto the piece of paper and said, no.
考虑这个人——这正是LaDonna的存在所要达到的目的，去引发同理心，那种她以前在现场时想要从主管Kevin那里得到的尊重。LaDonna把自己和他们放在主管室里，让他看到她——蓝色衬衫，和他一样。但LaDonna说，当她作为主管进来时，Kevin的反应并不是尊重。她说他的反应是，哇，他们肯定是为了招你进来而搜刮了桶底。LaDonna说Kevin会违反规定，不顾人们的医疗需求而随意更改时间表。LaDonna会纠正他。考虑这个人。当他告诉LaDonna更改工资单以便不支付一名保安应得的加班费时，LaDonna拿着那张纸说，不。
And then he took the paper, and he threw it back in my face. And he was like, you're always talking back. You're always talking back. It was like, I just-- I didn't know what to say. And then he was like I'm tired of seeing you niggers' faces, and he walked out the room. That was just like, wow. So now we know why you feel like I'm the bottom of the barrel and those kind of things and I'm disgusting. So thank you for letting me know.
然后他拿过那张纸，扔回我的脸上。他说，你总是回嘴。你总是回嘴。我就是……我不知道该说什么。然后他说，我厌倦了看到你们这些黑鬼的脸，然后他走出了房间。那感觉就像是，哇。所以现在我们知道为什么你觉得我是桶底之货，觉得那些，觉得我很恶心了。所以谢谢你让我知道。
I remember being so enraged. I was like, there's got to be a law against this. And I remember there was a book with all the codes and everything from the company. And I went through the book and I found discrimination, I found hostile work envir-- ugh, I'm sorry.
我记得当时非常愤怒。我想，一定有法律可以禁止这种事。我记得公司有一本包含所有准则的书。我翻遍了那本书，我发现了歧视，我发现了敌对工作环境……呃，抱歉。
That's OK.
没关系。
And I wrote it up. And I wrote the pages, and I did all this stuff, and I wrote a four-- I wrote a complaint. It was, like, four pages long. I turned it in to the woman who was in human resources. I gave it to the man-- I hand-delivered it to them. I can't experience this anymore. Like, I'm tired of working under Kevin. I said, every time I'm by myself with him, he finds a way to tear me down, talk to me disgusting. I'm tired of it. Forever I have to experience this, just because I stood up for myself? It's just not fair.
我写下来了。我写了几页，我做了所有这些事，我写了一个四……我写了一份投诉。足足四页长。我把它交给了人力资源部门的那个女人。我把它给了那个男人——我亲手交给了他们。我再也无法忍受这种经历了。就像，我厌倦了在Kevin手下工作。我说，每次我和他单独在一起，他就会找机会拆我台，说话真恶心。我厌倦了。仅仅因为我坚持了自己的立场，就必须永远经历这些？这太不公平了。
They gave me the most nonchalant response. Oh, Powell, you're reading too much into it. I told you before, Kevin's just like that. If you can't handle the position in there, let us know. We'll put you back in the field.
他们给了我最冷漠的回答。哦，Powell，你想得太多了。我以前告诉过你，Kevin就是那样。如果你应付不了那个职位，告诉我们。我们会把你调回现场。
Everyone has a boss. LaDonna complained about Kevin to their boss, Chris Timberlake, and to his boss, project manager Martin Feeney. Martin Feeney also declined to talk to us. There was a union for guards, but LaDonna wasn't a guard anymore. She was management. According to Allied protocol, every employee complaint triggers an investigation. LaDonna says nobody followed up with her about what happened with Kevin beyond that one conversation with HR and Martin Feeney, which she says ended with Martin Feeney telling her, kick him in the balls next time.
每个人都有老板。LaDonna向他们的老板Chris Timberlake，以及项目经理Martin Feeney投诉了Kevin。Martin Feeney也拒绝接受我们的采访。保安有一个工会，但LaDonna不再是保安了。她是管理层。根据Allied规定，每位员工的投诉都会触发调查。LaDonna说，除了那次与人力资源部门和Martin Feeney的谈话外，没人跟进Kevin的事，那次谈话以Martin Feeney告诉她“下次踢他蛋蛋”而告终。
LaDonna knew this strategy already. She knew it didn't work. When she was 19, working at Applebee's, she says a coworker grabbed her ass and said he liked Jamaican bodies. She turned around and smashed him in the face with a big metal spoon. Didn't help. LaDonna had tried all the things. They weren't working.
LaDonna已经知道这个策略了。她知道没用。她说她在Applebee's工作时，19岁，一个同事抓了她的屁股，说他喜欢牙买加人的身体。她转过身，用一把大金属勺子砸了他的脸。没用。LaDonna试过了所有办法。都没用。
And no matter how far I leaned into my career-- I made it-- I'm the first female to ever start there as a guard at my age and make it to a supervisor. I leaned all the way in without letting anyone touch me, with just showing I was capable-- I could read, I could type, I was able, I understood the job. I made it all the way to supervisor. Still, I'm still being harassed. It just didn't work. It worked as far-- OK, now I've excelled in my career, but I'm still being harassed. Now what? Now what do we do?
无论我如何在职业生涯中投入——我做到了——我是第一个以那个年纪从保安做起并升至主管的女性。我全身心投入，没有让任何人碰我，只是表现出我的能力——我能读、能写，我有能力，我了解工作。我一路晋升为主管。但我还是受到了骚扰。这根本没用。这只管用到……好吧，现在我在事业上出类拔萃了，但我还在受到骚扰。现在该怎么办？现在我们该做什么？
LaDonna settled on a new idea for how to fix it all at once. She could see clearly how the male supervisors were treating the guards now that she was on the inside. She could also suddenly see the female guards and how they were responding. She was in the office every day with another male supervisor, and the women guards would show up in there.
LaDonna想出了一个新主意，该如何一劳永逸地解决问题。现在她身在内部，能清楚地看到男主管是如何对待保安的。她也能突然看到女保安是如何回应的。她每天都和另一位男主管在办公室里，女保安会到那里来。
They come in, they're bringing him lunch, shirt open, breasts out-- oh, hi. So some of them were benefiting, using it as a tool to get what they wanted out of it. And watching them with the men supervisors, it was like, why are you doing that? But they're doing it for a good post, for overtime, for a better break.
她们走进来，给他带午餐，衬衫敞开，乳房露着——哦，嗨。所以她们中的一些人从中受益，把它当作工具来获取她们想要的东西。看着她们和男主管在一起，就像，你为什么那样做？但她们是为了好岗位、加班费、更好的休息时间而做的。
It's like, don't do that. Just don't do it. If we all would say no, it would make it easier for all of us saying no. But you saying yes makes it harder for me saying no. Let's just say no, because we're at work. Let's say no.
就像，别那样做。就是别做。如果我们都拒绝，那么所有人都拒绝会更容易。但你说了“是”，让我说“不”变得更难。我们一起说“不”吧，因为我们在工作。让我们说“不”。
This was it. When LaDonna heard Allied needed someone to train the new recruits, newly-hired guards, she immediately volunteered herself.
就是这个。当LaDonna听到Allied需要人来培训新员工时，她立刻主动请缨。
Let me be the first face they see.
让我成为他们看到的第一个面孔。
These people are new. She could teach them. This was her new idea. She would change the entire culture of the place by starting at the beginning, when people were hired. She would train them correctly. She could teach the women not to respond to sexual advances. She would teach them to focus on work, security. And all the new hires would take root in this place, like an invasive species. They would change the entire ecology. The supervisors would not respond to LaDonna telling them to change, so she'd change the world around them.
这些人是新手。她可以教他们。这是她的新主意。她要从头开始，在人们被录用时就重塑整个地方的文化。她会正确地培训他们。她可以教女性不要回应性骚扰。她会教她们专注于工作、安全。所有的应聘者都会像入侵物种一样在这个地方扎根。他们会改变整个生态。主管们不会理会LaDonna让他们改变的建议，所以她会改变他们周围的世界。
Chana Joffe-Walt. Coming up, the re-education campaign begins. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Chana Joffe-Walt。稍后，再教育运动开始。从芝加哥公共广播电台收听，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "LaDonna." We're telling the story of LaDonna Powell and watching as she brings her enormous sense of mission to the job of securing JFK airport in New York, and to making the company that she works for, Allied Universal, a better place to work. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The New Guard.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目叫“LaDonna”。我们讲述的是LaDonna Powell的故事，看着她如何带着强烈的使命感去确保纽约肯尼迪机场的安全，并努力让她工作的Allied Universal公司成为一个更好的工作场所。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，新势力。
So, as you heard in the first half of the show, LaDonna had tried managing up, to reshape her boss's behaviors. Now she went in the opposite direction. And she created something brand new. She was going to start from the beginning, training the new recruits. Again, here's Chana Joffe-Walt.
正如你在上半部分听到的，LaDonna曾尝试向上管理，重塑她老板的行为。现在她采取了截然相反的方向。她创造了一些全新的东西。她要从头开始，培训新招募的人。再次说明，这是Chana Joffe-Walt。
LaDonna did not actually have any experience teaching or training anyone. So she did what she does-- she read, collected tips, watched online videos about giving presentations. She bought The Essential HR Handbook and read about onboarding, how to set company culture from day one.
LaDonna实际上没有任何教学或培训经验。所以她做了她惯做的事——她阅读、收集建议、观看关于演示技巧的在线视频。她买了《人力资源基本手册》，阅读关于入职培训的内容，以及如何从第一天开始建立公司文化。
Because it talks about, in HR, knowing your people. So I made sure every time they came into the class I knew who was wearing-- oh, you had a pink shirt on yesterday. People like to know you know them.
因为书中提到了，在人力资源领域，要了解你的人。所以我确保每次他们进教室时，我都了解谁穿了什么——哦，你昨天穿了粉色衬衫。人们喜欢知道你了解他们。
First class, LaDonna opened with the piece of education people at Allied seemed to have missed-- how to act in a workplace. She held up the AlliedBarton employee handbook. She explained, Allied has a multimillion dollar contract to protect this airport. That is our job. It is what the airport, the client, wants us to be focused on 100% of the time.
第一节课，LaDonna从Allied似乎错过的教育开始——如何在工作场所行事。她举起AlliedBarton员工手册。她解释说，Allied有一份价值数百万美元的合同来保护这个机场。那是我们的工作。这是机场，也就是客户，希望我们百分之百专注的事情。
The client is paying us for a certain quality of work environment. The client is paying us for a certain quality of person working here. For one thing, I would always tell them, this is a sexual harassment-free environment. And I would say to them, you want to read this page-- I can't remember the page at this moment, but I always said, you want to read this page. You want to know your rights. This is a place where you should be able to come to work, not be touched or solicited for sex. You don't want to let people think it's OK to solicit you for sex. This is a place of security. No matter what's happening here, don't adapt to that.
客户为我们支付了一定质量的工作环境费用。客户支付了我们一定素质的人员在这里工作的费用。首先，我总是告诉他们，这是一个没有性骚扰的环境。我会对他们说，你们想读读这一页——我不记得现在是哪一页了，但我总是说，你们想读读这一页。你们要了解自己的权利。这是一个你应该能够来工作，不被骚扰或索要性服务的地方。不要让人们以为索要性服务是可以的。这是一个安全的地方。无论这里发生什么，都不要适应那个环境。
They should know they're allowed to use the bathroom. They should know they can't walk off the post. Things will happen here. And if it happens, you want to take note. That was always one of my biggest things to them-- you want to write it down. You have a right.
他们应该知道他们被允许使用洗手间。他们应该知道他们不能离开岗位。这里会发生事情。如果发生了，你要记录下来。那一直是我对他们最重要的事情之一——你要把它写下来。你有权利。
You were, like, starting a revolution.
你就像，在发起一场革命。
I was trying. And I'm like, listen, open your mind to what I'm saying to you. And then I would just give them morals my mom dropped in my brain, hoping it would stick to them.
我在尝试。我说，听着，敞开胸怀听我说的话。然后我会把妈妈灌输给我的道德准则传授给他们，希望这能留在他们脑子里。
Like what?
比如什么？
Like, take your book. She would always say that, because in West India, they say, "take your book," meaning "go to school." She's like, you don't need bagga fren, you don't need man, you don't need-- you need your book. I'm like, OK, this lady.
比如，带上你的书。她总是这么说，因为在西印度，他们说“take your book”，意思是“去上学”。她说，你不需要朋友，你不需要男人，你不需要……你需要你的书。我说，好吧，这位女士。
LaDonna was improvising her own book, her own workplace manifesto. She had gathered bits and pieces from this book and that one, adding her own experience, her insights, wisdom from her mom. And she was trying it out on her first audience. For a long time, LaDonna had imagined what her book would be if she ever wrote one. She told me she had even thought of a title, Do a Little More-- it's something her mom used to say to her. And her trainings did what all those best-selling motivational books do. She said, do what I did, it can work for you too. She encouraged them to push themselves, imagine themselves on a grand stage.
LaDonna在即兴创作她自己的书，她自己的工作场所宣言。她从这本书和那本书里收集片段，加入自己的经验、洞察力，以及妈妈的智慧。她正在第一批听众身上试验。很长一段时间以来，LaDonna一直想象如果她写书会写什么。她告诉我，她甚至想好了一个标题，“多做一点”——这是她妈妈过去常对她说的话。她的培训产生了那些畅销励志书所能产生的所有效果。她说，做我做的，这对你也有用。她鼓励他们逼自己一把，想象自己身处宏大的舞台。
Don't be afraid. Be motivated to go forward. You do a little more than the other workers and do your training, you elevate. You're worth it. It was like, you're definitely worth it.
不要害怕。要有前进的动力。你比其他员工多做一点，完成培训，你就会提升。你值得这样做。就像，你绝对值得。
People were into it. I talked to guards who went through the LaDonna Powell training, and it was a thing. It was motivating and clear. LaDonna trained hundreds of people after that-- new recruits, and she started to do refresher trainings for the existing guards. People would leave class saying, we're going to vote Powell for president. You've got my vote, Powell.
人们很投入。我和参加过LaDonna Powell培训的保安谈过，这确实是一回事。它充满动力且清晰。此后LaDonna培训了数百人——新入职的人，她还开始为现有保安进行复训。人们离开教室时会说，我们要投Powell当总统。你得到我的选票了，Powell。
She taught people from retail jobs and former military people, men and women. She liked them. The women were focused-- not on sexual favors but on work. There was one in her class who was super talkative, opinionated.
她培训了来自零售行业的人和前军人，男女都有。她喜欢他们。女性很专注——不是为了性恩惠，而是为了工作。她的班上有个人超级健谈，有自己的主见。
And she was like, you know what? I'm going to be a supervisor. And I was like, OK. Do it. You can do that. You can do whatever you want. Honestly, always in my mind, those guys are gone, and we can just fix it better.
她说，你知道吗？我要成为主管。我说，好的。去做吧。你能做到。你能做任何你想做的事。老实说，我心里一直认为，那些家伙已经过去了，我们可以把它修得更好。
Oh, you're picturing the future workplace?
哦，你在描绘未来的工作场所？
Right, up there-- if they had, like, two more women there, just to speak logic, like, no-- you know, just someone to say, no, instead of, yeah, dude, that's good, bro, yeah, do that-- it might be better.
对，就在那——如果他们能多两个女性，只是为了讲逻辑，就像，不……你知道，只是有人能说“不”，而不是“是，伙计，那很好，兄弟，做吧”——可能会更好。
LaDonna trained 330 people at Allied-- 80% of the workplace, between new people and refreshers. 80%. She felt good, like it was going well. And then, one day, LaDonna was teaching a refresher course. She was standing in front of the classroom, by the projector, in the middle of class, and a black guard raised his hand.
LaDonna在Allied培训了330人——占工作场所的80%，包括新人及复训者。80%。她感觉很好，觉得进展顺利。然后有一天，LaDonna在教授复训课程。她站在教室前面，投影仪旁边，课程进行到一半时，一名黑人保安举起了手。
He told me the story of the supervisor calling him a nigger. And he was like, it's not the first time. And this is in front of the class. This is is a class of-- roughly, this night, it had to be, like, 11 people in the class. And he's telling the story, and everyone knew. So I said to him, who else in here?
他告诉了我主管叫他黑鬼的故事。他说，这不是第一次了。而且是在全班面前。这是一个班级——那天晚上，大约有11个人。他在讲这个故事，大家都知道。所以我对他说，这里还有谁？
And they all were just looking at each other. I was like, you guys can tell me. I was like, you know you can trust me. I'll take it to management. And they were like, no one's going to do anything about him. They never do anything about him.
他们都互相看着。我说，你们可以告诉我。我说，你们知道可以信任我。我会把它带给管理层。他们说，没人会对他做什么。他们从不对他做什么。
They we're talking about Kevin, which LaDonna had already assumed. Again, we asked Kevin for a response to this. He declined.
他们谈论的是Kevin，LaDonna已经猜到了。我们再次要求Kevin回应此事。他拒绝了。
And I was just trying to tell them, listen, if you write it down, maybe-- you know, we can try. Let's just try.
我只是试图告诉他们，听着，如果你们把它写下来，也许……我们能试试。我们试一试吧。
When they said to you, who am I going to complain to, when you--
当你对他们说，我该向谁投诉时，当你……
I said, to me.
我说，向我。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
I said, you've said it to me, I'm not just going to leave it here. It's not OK. It really bothered me so much to even hear that being said. And the fact that the people we're managing are mostly African-American, minorities, Latin, that's a problem. You shouldn't be overseeing those people, because you don't value them either. You don't value us.
我说，你们已经对我说过了，我不会让它到此为止。这不对。听到那种话真的让我感到非常困扰。而且我们管理的人大多是非裔美国人、少数族裔、拉美裔，这是个问题。你不应该监督这些人，因为你也不看重他们。你不看重我们。
So I go to management. They look at me, they look at each other, they kind of smirk. They're like, you know how he is. I don't know why you keep taking this so personal. Well, sorry. The black color of my skin would be one reason. And that's not OK.
所以我去找管理层。他们看着我，互相看着，有点傻笑。他们说，你知道他是什么样的人。我不明白你为什么一直这么个人化。好吧，抱歉。我皮肤的颜色可能是一个原因。而且那不对。
Allied is an enormous, multibillion dollar company. LaDonna knew the rules come from the top, and these supervisors at JFK were not the top. Allied JFK is one of 20,000 Allied locations. Allied provides security to libraries and museums and malls and baseball stadiums and government buildings. Allied guards are in the waiting rooms of hospitals. They're standing at the gates of universities. They're riding Segways at parks. They protect nursing homes and resorts and construction sites. They are in all 50 states.
Allied是一家庞大的、价值数十亿美元的公司。LaDonna知道规矩是从上面下来的，而肯尼迪机场的这些主管不是高层。Allied肯尼迪机场是Allied 20000个地点中的一个。Allied为图书馆、博物馆、商场、棒球场和政府大楼提供安保。Allied保安在医院的候诊室里。他们站在大学的大门口。他们在公园里骑着赛格威。他们保护养老院、度假村和建筑工地。他们遍布50个州。
All of that to say, this is a huge company with a chain of command that expands well beyond the airport. Everyone has a boss, and there were many, many bosses at Allied. Good leadership was up there somewhere.
总之，这是一家巨大的公司，指挥链远超机场。每个人都有老板，Allied有许多许多老板。好的领导力应该在上面某个地方。
This is why LaDonna insisted her students report infractions. They needed documentation. Maybe if these written complaints built up, they could build a ladder up high enough to reach the responsible leaders. There were more complaints from guards in LaDonna's classes, especially in the refresher courses-- harassment, racist comments. Keep writing things down, she'd say. Take notes. Call this OSHA number and report a safety violation. A woman came to her and said Kevin had been harassing her.
这就是为什么LaDonna坚持她的学生报告违规行为。他们需要书面证明。也许如果这些书面投诉累积起来，他们就能搭起一架梯子，爬到足够高的地方去接触负责的领导。LaDonna班上的保安有更多投诉，尤其是在复训课程中——骚扰、种族主义言论。把事情写下来，她说。做记录。打那个OSHA电话报告安全违规。一个女人来找她，说Kevin一直在骚扰她。
So I said, did you write this down? And she was like, I don't know. You know how he is. And I'm like, I understand everything you're saying, but you have to fight for yourself. I'm going to go fight for you right now. But what I need you to promise me you're going to do is also fight for yourself, because there's a lot of fighting I'm doing right now for everybody, and I kind of need you guys to fight back also.
所以我说，你写下来了吗？她说，我不知道。你知道他是什么样的人。我说，我理解你说的所有话，但你必须为自己抗争。我现在就要去为你抗争。但我需要你向我保证你也会为自己抗争，因为我正在为所有人做很多抗争，我需要你们也反抗。
She did what I told her to do. And then that resulted in her being a target. So I don't know. It's like, I felt like I told her the right thing, honestly. I felt like I told all of them the right thing, because you are supposed to speak up for yourself. Why can they just not stop?
她照我说的做了。结果她成了目标。所以我不知道。就像，老实说，我觉得我告诉她的方式是对的。我觉得我告诉他们所有人都是对的，因为你应该为自己挺身而出。为什么他们就是不能停下来？
Do you still feel, though, that that was the right-- the approach that you took to those classes was, I'm going to teach people to be like me.
不过，你仍然觉得那是对的吗——你对那些课程采取的方法是，我要教人们变得像我一样。
Yes.
是的。
And this woman is saying to you, I did the thing that you told me to, and it did not end up well for me so far, right?
而这个女人对你说，我照你说的做了，但目前对我来说结局并不好，对吧？
Right.
对。
Does that make you doubt your approach?
这让你怀疑自己的方法了吗？
It doesn't make me doubt my approach. It makes me feel like their response is wrong.
这没让我怀疑自己的方法。这让我觉得他们的反应是错的。
There was one thing that did make LaDonna doubt everything. One woman, an enthusiastic, ambitious guard whom LaDonna had trained a few months earlier, came to her and told her she'd been sexually assaulted by another guard-- not on the premises and not during work, but by a coworker. LaDonna says she listened and told her that it wasn't OK, what had happened to her, and they needed to do something. No, no, no, the woman responded, she just wanted to tell someone. LaDonna says she didn't think anything needed to happen.
有一件事确实让LaDonna怀疑一切。一个女人，LaDonna几个月前培训过的一名热情、有抱负的保安，来找她，说她被另一名保安性侵了——不是在工作场所，也不是在工作期间，而是被一名同事。LaDonna说她听了，告诉她那是不对的，不管发生了什么，他们需要做点什么。不，不，不，那个女人回应说，她只是想告诉某个人。LaDonna说她不认为需要发生什么。
It's like somebody has to help her. And I can't hold something like that inside, because then it's going to drive me insane. I just couldn't. There's no way.
就像有人必须帮助她。我不能把那种事憋在心里，否则会让我发疯。我做不到。根本不可能。
LaDonna went to the other supervisors. She says she told them the woman had been raped, and she told them who raped her. She asked the woman's direct supervisor, at the very least, don't put her on duty with him. But LaDonna says he didn't listen. And every day after that, LaDonna went to work, and so did the woman, right alongside the man.
LaDonna去找了其他主管。她说她告诉他们那个女人被强奸了，还告诉了他们是谁强奸的。她要求那个女人的直接主管，至少不要让她和那个人一起值班。但LaDonna说他没听。在那之后的每一天，LaDonna去工作，那个女人也去，和那个男人在一起。
I don't know what kind of psychological warfare that is. I don't even know how she still does it-- currently working, and they still put her with him after they found out. I don't know. It makes my skin crawl.
我不知道那是什么样的心理战。我甚至不知道她是怎么坚持的——目前还在工作，他们发现后还是把她和他放在一起。我不知道。这让我毛骨悚然。
The woman did not want to be interviewed for the radio. She wanted to handle this her own way. LaDonna wanted to go to upper management, but the woman didn't want to. She wanted to keep her job. She told LaDonna she didn't need anything to be done. To LaDonna, that was acceptance.
那个女人不想接受广播采访。她想用自己的方式处理。LaDonna想找高层管理人员，但那个女人不想。她想保住工作。她告诉LaDonna她不需要做任何事。对LaDonna来说，那是接受。
People are not supposed to take from you without your permission. I just wanted her to understand she's worth fighting for. They should make you feel worth fighting for. She just-- ugh, she just doesn't see it that way.
人们不应该在没有你允许的情况下从你那里索取。我只是想让她明白她值得抗争。他们应该让你觉得你值得抗争。她只是……呃，她就是看不开。
And there was nothing, no evidence LaDonna could point to to convince her otherwise. LaDonna was trying to force a reckoning that would require this woman, and everyone on staff, to see themselves differently, to be vigilant at all times. But many of them were flagging. They were losing their sense of urgency, turning inward, away from revolution. LaDonna never turned away. Nine months after this, she was pulled into a meeting with HR and the project manager, the big boss at Allied JFK.
没有任何证据能让LaDonna说服她。LaDonna试图强迫一种清算，这要求这个女人和所有员工以不同的方式看待自己，时刻保持警惕。但他们中的许多人都在动摇。他们正在失去紧迫感，转向内部，远离革命。LaDonna从未转向。九个月后，她被叫去与人力资源部门和项目经理，即Allied肯尼迪机场的大老板开会。
I was like, am I fired? I asked three times. Am I fired? Tell me what I'm fired for. Am I fired for talking up?
我说，我被开除了吗？我问了三次。我被开除了吗？告诉我我为什么被开除。我是因为说话被开除的吗？
And he's like, oh, I wish you would close your mouth. And I said, what am I fired for? And I started reeling off everything. Am I fired for talking up? About what, the sexual harassment? About being called a nigger?
他说，哦，我希望你能闭上嘴。我说，我为什么被开除？我开始列举一切。我是因为说话被开除的吗？关于什么，性骚扰？关于被叫黑鬼？
And I started saying ev-- I said, all the stuff that goes on in this place, everybody sleeping with everybody, people don't even do their job. And I just started saying everything to him. I said, so am I fired? No, you're not fired. We'll call you in a few days, and we'll let you know something.
我开始说所……我说，这地方发生的所有事，每个人都和每个人睡觉，人们甚至不好好工作。我开始对他说了所有事。我说，那我被开除了吗？不，你没被开除。我们几天后会叫你，我们会通知你一些事。
LaDonna says they didn't call. Weeks later, when she logged into Allied's online portal, that's where she saw she had been terminated. LaDonna had cycled through so many different strategies at Allied, but she had actually never thought about a lawsuit until this point. And when she talked to a lawyer, the lawyer said, this would be a stronger case if you knew other people had experienced the same thing.
LaDonna说他们没打电话。几周后，当她登录Allied的在线门户网站时，看到自己已被终止合同。LaDonna在Allied尝试过这么多不同的策略，但在此之前她从未想过诉讼。当她和律师交谈时，律师说，如果你知道其他人也有同样的经历，这个案子会更有力。
I do, LaDonna said. I trained them. I trained everybody. I was a supervisor. I saw everything. The lawyer perked up. Well, if you can get other people to join you, you'd have a stronger case.
我知道，LaDonna说。我培训过他们。我培训了所有人。我是主管。我看到了一切。律师振作了起来。好吧，如果你能让其他人加入你，你的案子会更有力。
LaDonna sat down, made a list of women she knew had experienced harassment and were no longer at Allied, and one morning she went through the list. The first woman she called said, I can't talk. She wouldn't explain why. LaDonna called the second woman, can't talk. Again, why? Eventually, this woman explained she had already sued Allied herself, settled the case, and signed a non-disclosure agreement-- an NDA. Next woman LaDonna called, same thing.
LaDonna坐下来，列了一份她知道经历过骚扰且已不在Allied工作的女性名单，一天早上她把名单过了一遍。她打的第一个女人说，我不能说。她不解释为什么。LaDonna给第二个女人打电话，不能说。再次，为什么？最终，这个女人解释说她自己已经起诉了Allied，达成了和解，并签署了一份保密协议——NDA。LaDonna打给下一个女人，也是一样。
Wow. This is what they've been doing. These guys are still here. It's insane. It's kind of insane to me.
哇。这就是他们一直在做的事。这些家伙还在那。这太疯狂了。对我来说有点疯狂。
Did you even know that was an option?
你甚至知道那是一个选项吗？
I didn't.
我不知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
But you know what? It's not an option. I hope you guys are listening. It's not an option.
但你知道吗？这不是一个选项。我希望你们在听。这不是一个选项。
Wait, who are you talking to, "I hope you guys are listening"?
等等，你在和谁说话，“我希望你们在听”？
Allied.
Allied。
Oh.
哦。
I hope they're listening because I feel like, how many times do they get to do that? How many times do they get to do that before they actually take this serious and start making a change?
我希望他们在听，因为我觉得，他们能做多少次这种事？在他们真正认真对待并开始做出改变之前，他们能做多少次？
We found court records for 11 lawsuits against Allied at JFK that allege workplace discrimination. It's unclear how many more Allied might have settled before the cases formally went to court. So LaDonna wasn't alone trying to push back. Other women were fighting back too. She had no idea. They did come forward. The information was conveyed to a higher authority, to a court of law, and it did not make LaDonna or these women more secure. It made them invisible.
我们找到了11起针对Allied在肯尼迪机场工作歧视的诉讼法庭记录。不清楚Allied在案件正式上庭前可能和解了多少起。所以LaDonna并不是唯一一个试图反抗的人。其他女性也在反抗。她根本不知道。她们确实站了出来。信息被传达给了更高的权威，传达给了法庭，但这并没有让LaDonna或这些女性更安全。它让她们隐形了。
LaDonna filed her lawsuit last October. Soon after, three more people from Allied got in touch, asking to join her lawsuit. And then, after that, there were two more workplace discrimination lawsuits filed against Allied at other New York sites-- the World Trade Center and LaGuardia Airport. LaDonna waited. Everyone has a boss.
LaDonna去年十月提起了诉讼。不久之后，另外三个来自Allied的人联系了她，要求加入她的诉讼。此后，在Allied其他纽约站点——世界贸易中心和拉瓜迪亚机场——又提起了两起工作歧视诉讼。LaDonna等待着。每个人都有老板。
What else do you guys need to happen-- just what else, before you say, all right, let's get these guys out of here, they've went too far?
你们还需要发生什么——到底还需要什么，你们才会说，好了，把这些人赶走，他们做得太过分了？
OK, my name is Steve Jones, and I'm the CEO of Allied Universal.
好的，我的名字是Steve Jones，我是Allied Universal的CEO。
Steve Jones became CEO in 2016 when his security company, Universal Services of America, merged with AlliedBarton, becoming the largest security firm in North America. He told me LaDonna was fired because of her failure to comply with her supervisory duties. He wouldn't say more about what duties but was clear it was not for speaking up about sexual harassment and racial discrimination. He said he only heard those complaints after LaDonna filed her lawsuit and there was a local news story about it. He adds, "This is despite Allied's many systems in place for employees to communicate concerns."
Steve Jones在2016年成为CEO，当时他的安保公司Universal Services of America与AlliedBarton合并，成为北美最大的安保公司。他告诉我，LaDonna被开除是因为她未能履行主管职责。他没有具体说是什么职责，但很清楚不是因为举报性骚扰和种族歧视。他说他只有在LaDonna提起诉讼并且有当地新闻报道后才听到这些投诉。他补充说，“尽管Allied有许多供员工沟通顾虑的系统。”
There's literally a half a dozen avenues to where you could communicate to us, and then we would launch an immediate investigation. Why didn't LaDonna Powell choose to take one of those avenues of communication and inform us of it? I don't know. We're obviously--
我们字面上有一半打通了你可以与我们沟通的渠道，然后我们会立即启动调查。为什么LaDonna Powell不选择其中一种沟通渠道通知我们？我不知道。我们显然……
So wait, you're saying she didn't-- you're saying that she did not report any of this behavior, verbally or in a written form to supervisors or HR?
等等，你是说她没有……你是说她没有口头或书面形式向主管或人力资源部门报告任何这些行为吗？
What I'm telling you, yeah, is the first time we were made aware of this was through the media.
我告诉你的是，是的，我们第一次通过媒体了解到这一点。
There's lawsuits-- I mean, there's lawsuits going back to 2014. There's three lawsuits that describe very similar behavior that LaDonna is describing in the-- there's two more in 2015. There's formal complaints that I've seen written to HR that describe very similar behavior. There's calls to OSHA about being denied bathroom breaks. There's an employee at Allied JFK who left a letter and distributed it publicly that described widespread sexual misconduct by supervisors. And not to mention, I've been talking to many, many staff at Allied who have heard about these things. So it does not seem true that you were not made aware of some of the issues that LaDonna's raising.
有诉讼……我的意思是，诉讼可以追溯到2014年。有三起诉讼描述了LaDonna在……中描述的非常相似的行为，2015年还有两起。我见过写给人力资源的正式投诉，描述了非常相似的行为。有人给OSHA打电话投诉被拒绝上厕所。Allied肯尼迪机场的一名员工留了一封信并公开发布，描述了主管们广泛的性不当行为。更不用说，我一直在和Allied的许多员工交谈，他们都听说过这些事。所以你并不知晓LaDonna提出的问题，这似乎不是真的。
So what I would tell you is LaDonna Powell did not make us aware of her specific claims. And what I would say is, with regards to any other claims, every claim that gets brought to our attention is investigated thoroughly and responded to. And obviously, if it's a pending legal matter, I clearly can't comment on that.
所以我可以告诉你的是，LaDonna Powell没有让我们知晓她的具体主张。我想说的是，关于任何其他主张，每一个引起我们注意的主张都会经过彻底调查并做出回应。显然，如果这是一个未决的法律事项，我显然无法评论。
No, they were settled. There are lawsuits that were settled. And for the most part, it seems like the people who settled those lawsuits signed nondisclosure agreements, so they can't talk about it.
不，它们已经和解了。有些诉讼已经和解了。而且大多数情况下，似乎那些和解诉讼的人签署了保密协议，所以他们不能谈论它。
OK. That does not change the fact that we don't take all allegations of either harassment or discrimination very, very seriously, and then we investigate each and every one of them.
好的。这并不能改变我们没有非常、非常认真地对待所有骚扰或歧视指控的事实，我们会对每一项进行调查。
One of the things that did not make sense to me was, if there are multiple complaints about certain employees, and Allied is having to pay out money in settlements over and over, why not just get rid of those managers? Setting aside what's fair or what's right, it just seems like there'd be strong financial reasons to do that. I asked him what he made of the fact that some of the same men were accused again and again.
对我来说不合理的一件事是，如果有关于某些员工的多项投诉，而且Allied不得不一次又一次地支付和解金，为什么不直接摆脱那些经理？撇开公平或正确不谈，似乎财务上有充分的理由这样做。我问他，有些人反复被指控，他对此怎么看。
We can't speculate that because someone has an allegation that that means those facts are correct. Again, our position--
我们不能因为有人提出了指控就推测事实是正确的。再次声明，我们的立场……
Of course, but it's repeated. I mean, that's the difference, right? It's not a single allegation. It's repeated allegations that are similar to one another against the same people.
当然，但它是重复的。我的意思是，那是区别，对吧？不是单一的指控。是针对同一批人反复出现相似的指控。
And again, any time an allegation is made, we conduct a thorough investigation-- is that allegation true? Is there a portion of it that is true? And what type of behavior was being done or wasn't being done? We have to get to the facts.
再次声明，任何时候有人提出指控，我们都会进行彻底调查——那个指控是真的吗？它是部分真实吗？做了什么行为或没做什么？我们必须弄清事实。
Allied says that is what they're trying to do now. They told me that since the lawsuit was filed, JFK management and supervisors have received training on discrimination and harassment, and HR staff got specialized training on how to respond to such matters. They've launched their own investigation and an independent investigation into what happened. Those investigations got started seven months ago-- which, to be clear, was four years after LaDonna says she first complained verbally and filed a written complaint against Kevin.
Allied说这就是他们现在正努力做的。他们告诉我，自从诉讼提起以来，肯尼迪机场的管理层和主管接受了关于歧视和骚扰的培训，人力资源人员接受了如何处理此类事项的专业培训。他们已经启动了自己内部的调查，以及对所发生事件的独立调查。那些调查在七个月前就开始了——这需要明确一下，是在LaDonna说她第一次口头抱怨并对Kevin提起书面投诉四年后。
Kevin and the four other men named in LaDonna's lawsuit denied all the allegations to us through their lawyers. I got an email response from the lawyer for Kevin McNamara and Chris Timberlake and the head boss at Allied JFK, Martin Feeney. It said, "We're confident that once the facts of the case come to light, it will be clear that Mr. Feeney, Mr. Timberlake, and Mr. McNamara did nothing wrong. It is unfortunate that these individuals' professional reputations are being tarnished as this case is debated in the court of public opinion."
Kevin和LaDonna诉讼中提到的其他四个人通过律师向我们否认了所有指控。我收到了Kevin McNamara、Chris Timberlake和Allied肯尼迪机场老板Martin Feeney的律师的电子邮件回复。上面写着，“我们相信一旦案件事实大白，就会清楚Feeney先生、Timberlake先生和McNamara先生没有做错任何事。不幸的是，当这个案件在公众舆论的法庭上争论不休时，这些人的专业声誉正受到玷污。”
There is one other investigation to come out of this lawsuit. The Port Authority, which runs New York's airports, says it is now reviewing LaDonna's allegations, and others, as well. A statement from the Port Authority says, they'll "take aggressive measures against Allied if they find those allegations to be true." And then, just recently, I started to hear rumors about some aggressive measures. I started to hear that the entire leadership of Allied JFK was gone.
此诉讼还有另一项调查。负责纽约机场的港务局表示，它现在也在审查LaDonna的指控以及其他指控。港务局的一份声明称，如果发现那些指控属实，他们将“对Allied采取积极措施”。然后，就在最近，我开始听到一些关于积极措施的传闻。我开始听说Allied肯尼迪机场的整个领导层都走了。
Oh, it's beautiful now.
哦，现在好多了。
This is a guard who works at Allied currently. She didn't want me to use her name. None of these workers did.
这是一名目前在Allied工作的保安。她不想让我使用她的名字。这些工人都不想。
I didn't believe it at first, because I thought maybe it was just a rumor, but then my phone started blowing up, so I was like, oh, wow. Wow.
起初我不敢相信，因为我以为那只是谣言，但后来我的手机炸了，所以我想，哦，哇。哇。
Yeah, it's about time. It's like, how can they get away with this, and why isn't someone doing something about it?
是啊，是时候了。就像，他们怎么能逃脱惩罚，为什么没有人对此做点什么？
The Allied guards say management did not explain what happened to the supervisors, or even why something was done. But they say they all know why it was done-- LaDonna.
Allied保安说，管理层没有解释主管们发生了什么，甚至没有解释为什么要采取某种行动。但他们说他们都知道原因——LaDonna。
I love it. I thank her for moving all these no-good people out, who have so many records on accusing women and doing all that stuff. I thank her.
我喜欢。我感谢她把所有这些没用的、有那么多指控女性记录和做所有那些事的人赶走。我感谢她。
And for years, you've heard the people doing stuff. And all of a sudden, bingo, finally something was getting taken care of. Yeah.
多年来，你听到了人们在做那些事。然后突然，宾果，终于有事被处理了。是啊。
A lot of people I spoke with didn't want to share their opinions on the record at all. And then there was this woman, who said she couldn't talk to me, but then stood next to her coworker yelling while I interviewed him.
我和许多人交谈，他们根本不想公开分享自己的观点。然后是这个女人，她说她不能跟我说话，但在我采访她同事时站在旁边大喊大叫。
Yeah. They said that women are tired of what's going on--
是啊。她们说女性对发生的事感到厌倦——
Yeah, you get tired of it.
是啊，你厌倦了。
It's true. It's like, you know--
这是真的。就像，你知道……
After a while, [INAUDIBLE].
过了一会儿，[听不清]。
Yeah, enough is enough. And--
是啊，够了就是够了。而且……
It's always been a big issue.
这一直是个大问题。
Yeah. As you said, it's always been a big issue.
是啊。就像你说的，这一直是个大问题。
Women are speaking out now.
女性现在在发声。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
Allied told me three people were fired. They wouldn't tell me who. As far as I can tell, Kevin McNamara and Chris Timberlake were not fired. They, along with most of the leadership from Allied JFK, were reassigned-- meaning they still work for Allied but not at JFK. I asked Allied CEO Steve Jones why many of the supervisors were reassigned.
Allied告诉我三个人被开除了。他们没告诉我谁。据我所知，Kevin McNamara和Chris Timberlake没有被开除。他们和Allied肯尼迪机场的大多数领导层一起被重新分配了——这意味着他们仍然为Allied工作，但不在肯尼迪机场。我问Allied CEO Steve Jones，为什么许多主管被重新分配。
So, we reassign employees all the time, whether it's promotion opportunities or new different challenges or--
所以，我们一直在重新分配员工，无论是晋升机会还是新的不同挑战还是……
Right. But are they being moved because they were at fault of some form of harassment or discrimination?
对。但他们是因为犯了某种形式的骚扰或歧视才被调动的吗？
No. So, I would say-- are some of the allegations found to be true? I would say no.
不。所以，我想说……指控中有属实的吗？我会说没有。
So why are people being reassigned?
那为什么人们被重新分配？
Well, again, we reassign people-- we reassign people all the time.
嗯，再说一次，我们重新分配人员——我们一直在重新分配人员。
It's just not an answer. Somebody just say it. We hired these guys. They're animals. We fucked up. We must stop. As a company, we frown upon this, and we're making changes. What's so hard to say that?
这根本不是答案。有人说出来就好了。我们雇佣了这些家伙。他们是野兽。我们搞砸了。我们必须停止。作为一家公司，我们不赞成这样做，我们正在做出改变。说出这些话有什么难的？
It occurred to me at some point that I've asked LaDonna the same question almost every time I've talked with her, did that make you feel powerful? I've asked her this about so many different things. Did that make you feel powerful when you made it to supervisor, when you were training all those people, when a fancy Manhattan law firm filed a lawsuit on your behalf, when the CEO of the company was responding directly to your complaints?
我曾有段时间想到，每次和她谈话时，我几乎都会问LaDonna同样的问题，这让你感到强大吗？关于那么多不同的事，我都这样问过她。当你升为主管时，当你培训所有那些人时，当一家高档曼哈顿律师事务所代表你提起诉讼时，当公司CEO直接回应你的投诉时，这让你感到强大吗？
No. LaDonna's answer was always no. It did not make her feel powerful. It was the same when the leadership of Allied JFK was removed. LaDonna heard that news, especially the part about the men from Allied being reassigned, and she was not thinking about her power. She was thinking about theirs. She was imagining Kevin arriving at his new job, putting on his same Allied uniform every day.
没有。LaDonna的回答总是没有。这没让她感到强大。Allied肯尼迪机场的领导层被免职时也是一样。LaDonna听到那个消息，特别是关于Allied的人被重新分配的部分，她想的不是自己的权力。她想的是他们的。她想象Kevin到达他的新工作地点，每天穿上同样的Allied制服。
That you can continue to walk around, just doing whatever you want to whomever you want, however, and nobody can touch you, it's almost like you're the boogeyman. You're untouchable.
你仍然可以四处走动，对任何人做你想做的任何事，无论如何，没人能动你，这几乎就像你是怪物一样。你是不可触碰的。
What LaDonna could now see was that he was protected, thoroughly, and she was not. She was alone. What LaDonna believed from all those self-help books is you have the power. There may be barriers, but if you act right, set your mind right, if you're strategic and ingenious, you can thwart their efforts to take your power away.
LaDonna现在能看到的是，他受到了保护，非常彻底，而她没有。她孤身一人。LaDonna从所有那些励志书中相信的是，你有力量。可能存在障碍，但如果你表现得体，心态端正，如果你有战略性且聪明，你可以阻挠他们夺走你的权力。
This news made her feel like, not really, because, yeah, everybody has a boss, but it was not just Kevin. It was not just the supervisors. It was also the project manager and the HR manager and the legal department at Allied Universal that paid women and the law that allows them to do that. It was a system designed to withstand her refusal to comply, to absorb her whole onslaught, all her strategic thought, passionately executed, carefully taught. It just ate it up and kept doing its thing. And now that LaDonna has seen all of that, she's not sure how to see herself.
这个消息让她觉得，不完全是，因为，是的，每个人都有老板，但不仅仅是Kevin。不仅仅是主管。还有Allied Universal的项目经理、人力资源经理、法律部门，他们支付钱给女性，还有法律允许他们那样做。这是一个设计用来抵御她拒绝配合的系统，用来吸收她所有的猛攻，所有她热情执行、仔细教授的战略思想。它只是把它吞了下去，继续做它的事。现在LaDonna看到了这一切，她不确定该如何看待自己。
I just-- I keep having these moments, like, it still leaves this lasting feeling that I was so vulnerable to these people, and they damaged me.
我只是……我一直有这种时刻，就像，它仍然留下了这种持久的感觉，即我在这些人面前是如此脆弱，他们伤害了我。
That damage is not visible, except to her. LaDonna still works at the airport. She works for the government now, for Customs and Border Protection. She's making more money, and it's a more prestigious job. LaDonna walks Terminal Four, her torso doubled in size by her bulletproof vest, head high, scanning the area like someone who owns the place. A couple months back, she was at work--
那种伤害是看不见的，除了她自己。LaDonna仍然在机场工作。她现在为政府工作，为海关和边境保护局工作。她挣得更多，这是一份更有声望的工作。LaDonna走在四号航站楼，身体被防弹背心撑大了两倍，昂着头，扫描着该区域，就像这里的主人一样。几个月前，她在工作——
And I'm walking. I have a M4 in my hand, my vest, pistol on my side. I'm walking, and I'm doing an escort. It's, like, five of us, and we're escorting someone. He's a diplomat.
我走着。手里拿着一把M4，背心，腰间有手枪。我走着，正在护送。就像，我们五个人，正在护送某人。他是外交官。
She's not allowed to say from where.
不允许说来自哪里。
He gave us a little pin and everything from his country. It's a regular day. And so we're escorting him. And we're walking, and everything's fine. And then I see one of the men.
他给了我们一点胸针和他国家的什么东西。这是正常的一天。所以我们护送他。走着，一切都很好。然后我看到了其中一个男人。
One of the men from Allied, a supervisor named Osvaldo Ortiz, the guy LaDonna says let the guard bleed on herself instead of giving her a bathroom break. He was coming into Terminal Four to get a coffee from Dunkin' Donuts.
Allied的其中一个男人，一个叫Osvaldo Ortiz的主管，LaDonna说他让保安尿在身上而不让他上厕所的那个家伙。他正走进四号航站楼，从Dunkin' Donuts买咖啡。
And then I just-- literally, I'm walking, and I'm fine. I'm talking, duh-duh, we're laughing, very militant, walking. And I'm fine. I got my gun. I'm holding it like this.
然后我只是……字面上，我走着，我很好。我说，嗒嗒，我们笑着，非常军事化地走着。我很好。我有枪。我像这样拿着它。
And I turn, and I get a sign of him. And then he sees me. And then I just turned my whole body, shifted to the left, and I ducked down.
然后我转过身，看到了他。他看到了我。然后我转过整个身体，向左转，蹲了下去。
LaDonna ducked as she was telling this to me. This is a man who, at this point in time, has no official power over her. She doesn't work for him. She's not financially dependent on him.
LaDonna在告诉我这些时蹲下了。这是一个在此刻对她没有任何官方权力的人。她不为他工作。她不需要经济依赖他。
Literally, I am-- I felt afraid. It's like, I'm nervous. Like, I started sweating and everything. It's like, why am I scared of this guy? It doesn't make sense to me. Regardless of me being, oh, badass Customs Agent with a gun, still the sight of him makes me cringe.
字面上，我——我感到害怕。就像，我很紧张。我开始出汗等等。就像，我为什么怕这个家伙？这对我来说说不通。不管我是个带着枪的坏蛋海关探员，仅仅看到他还是让我畏缩。
And you're escorting a fancy diplomat.
你还在护送一位高档外交官。
Exactly.
准确地说。
Who's here for important business.
他来这里办重要业务的。
Yes.
是的。
Who needs your protection because you are able to provide protection.
他需要你的保护，因为你有能力提供保护。
Protection. Right, right. And then I feel like I couldn't protect myself in that moment, yes.
保护。对，对。然后我觉得在那一刻我无法保护自己，是的。
And you have a gun.
而且你有枪。
And I have a gun. It's kind of horrible.
而且我有枪。这有点可怕。
Yeah. And that guy has a Dunkin' Donuts coffee.
是啊。而那个家伙拿着Dunkin' Donuts的咖啡。
Coffee And I still feel, yeah, at his mercy. So power? No. I feel like I am caged because of them.
咖啡。我仍然觉得，是的，任他摆布。所以权力？没有。我觉得我因为他们被囚禁了。
The cage is invisible, of course-- or it was until recently, just like the NDAs, and the reassignments, and everything else LaDonna can now see. She's still trying to map the contours of this cage, its full size and shape. It's hard. It's not written down anywhere or clearly marked. And that's what makes it scary. LaDonna needs to know exactly what she's dealing with. Then she can figure out her next move.
囚笼当然是隐形的——或者直到最近，就像保密协议、重新分配，以及LaDonna现在能看到的其他一切。她仍然在试图绘制这个囚笼的轮廓、它的大小和形状。很难。它没写在任何地方，也没清晰标注。这就是它可怕的地方。LaDonna需要确切知道她在处理什么。然后她可以弄清楚她的下一步动作。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our program.
Chana Joffe-Walt是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SECURITY" BY ETTA JAMES]
[音乐播放 - Etta James的“Security”]
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Wu. The people who put together a show includes Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton. Mixing help today from Katherine Rae Mondo and Sharif Youssef. Editing help from Sarah Koenig and Nancy Updike. Special thanks today Rebecca [? Vitale-Dokolah, ?] Nava EtShalom, [? Amina ?] [? Kotkin, ?] and Matt Chase.
好吧，我们的节目今天由Diane Wu制作。把节目放在一起的人包括Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Chana Joffe-Walt、Seth Lind、Miki Meek、Alvin Melathe、Nadia Reiman、Robyn Semien、Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed。我们的主编是Susan Burton。今天的混音帮助来自Katherine Rae Mondo和Sharif Youssef。Sarah Koenig和Nancy Updike提供了编辑帮助。特别感谢Rebecca [? Vitale-Dokolah, ?] Nava EtShalom, [? Amina ?] [? Kotkin, ?] 和Matt Chase。
It feels crazy to say this, but this is the very last week we are working with two of the people who you never hear on the radio but who have helped run the administrative side of things here at our radio show just for years-- Elise Bergerson and Kimberly Henderson. They are both off to bigger adventures elsewhere. We are so dependent on them and on a million things they do every day. It is not entirely clear how this is going to work around here, for those of us who are still here. If we are not on the air next week, that is the reason why. You guys, we will miss you. Come back. Visit.
说出这话感觉很疯狂，但这确实是我们与两位人员共事的最后一周，你们在广播中从未听到过，但他们只是多年来一直帮助我们运营广播节目行政方面的事——Elise Bergerson和Kimberly Henderson。她们都要去别处进行更大的冒险。我们非常依赖她们，依赖她们每天做的数百万件事。对于我们这些还在这里的人来说，这里将如何运作还不太清楚。如果下周我们没在广播中，这就是原因。你们，我们会想念你们的。回来。拜访。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. Or get the This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he keeps infiltrating my Facebook account. And when I call and ask him why, why are you doing this, he says--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过600集的档案。或者获取This American Life应用程序。This American Life由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他一直在渗透我的Facebook账户。当我打电话问他为什么，你为什么这么做，他说——
I'm a Russian bad boy.
我是个俄罗斯坏小子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。